todos estamos de acuerdo bolo de
mercedenski es el hombre del año el
Héroe del momento celenski se merece
toda nuestra admiración y de hecho los
que seáis veteranos seguidores de este
canal ya sabéis que el año pasado por
estas mismas fechas le dimos uno de
nuestros premios visualpolitik 2021 es
decir que nosotros hemos defendido a
zelensky incluso cuando muy pocos sabían
quién era
ahora bien como todos los políticos el
presidente de Ucrania no es lógicamente
perfecto el hecho de resistir tan
heroicamente la invasión rusa la ha
convertido en un líder de talla mundial
y le ha asegurado un puesto los libros
de Historia sin embargo Tenemos que
tener claro que eso no puede implicar
nunca dar cheques en blanco y mucho
menos a un político por mucho que se
merezca nuestro aplauso y desde luego lo
merece lo peor que podemos hacer siempre
es sacralizar una figura política
Y créeme este hombre tiene una de las
vidas más improbables que hemos conocido
está llena de sorpresas por ejemplo
ahora mismo todos le vemos como el gran
antagonista de Putin verdad sin embargo
zelensky ganó las elecciones entre otras
muchas cosas porque era el candidato más
neutral entre quienes defendían seguir
Mirando a Moscú y quienes preferían
centrarse exclusivamente en occidente
Así que la pregunta que nos hacemos Es
cómo llegó un cómico a convertirse en
presidente de su país Cuál fue su
política antes de la Guerra de Ucrania
qué aciertos y qué errores ha cometido
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
selensky ganó las elecciones tras
interpretar en una conocida serie cómica
a un ingenuo y al mismo tiempo honesto
profesor que fortuitamente y gracias a
un vídeo de YouTube se convirtió en el
presidente de Ucrania esto hizo que
cuando ganó las elecciones en la vida
real muchos no le tomaran en serio Pero
de alguna forma Aunque suene
descabellado podríamos llegar a decir
que zelensky el expresidente de Estados
Unidos Ronald Reagan tienen algunos
parecidos razonables la primera
similitud es más que obvia ambos se
convirtieron en estrellas mediáticas
antes de dar el paso a la política de
hecho esto es lo que decía Putin cuando
zelensky ganó las elecciones
es un simple actor y actuar como alguien
no te convierte en alguien Vladimir
Putin Vladimir delanski nació en 1978 en
una importante ciudad Industrial que
formaba parte del Antiguo Unión
soviética Y sí la lengua materna desde
la esquí no es el ucraniano sino el ruso
como dato curioso os diré que volodimir
es el nombre ucraniano para Vladimir es
decir que en cierto modo Putin que
comparten el mismo nombre solo que en
distintos idiomas
de una familia académica su padre o
Alexander era un científico y matemático
que fue el jefe de departamento
informático de una importante
universidad desde 1995 su madre rima es
una ingeniera retirada de familia judía
igual que su marit y de hecho con una
fuerte descendencia judía zelenski es el
primer presidente judío de la historia
de Ucrania no me digáis que no resulta
irónico que todavía que de gente que le
llame nazi pero cambiando de tema la
pregunta que podemos hacernos ahora es
pero realmente era tan solo un actor
Pues bien Lo cierto es que a pesar de
que siempre estuvo más ligado al mundo
del espectáculo Lo cierto es que
zelensky es graduado en derecho por la
universidad de gift y eso no es todo
antes de ser presidente celeskin no solo
era un actor cómico sino también y sobre
todo un empresario comenzó de la mano de
la cadena de habla rusa kvn donde en un
programa llamado el club de los alegres
ingeniosos se realizaban sql seres de
comedia a través de distintos equipos
que representaban ciudades ucranianas el
equipo de zelensquí Herald 95 recordad
este nombre Porque luego va a ser
importante
[Música]
Pues bienski le fue tan bien con sus
amigos de 95 que decidieron fundar una
productora con el mismo nombre y no
hablamos precisamente de una productora
pequeña de lo que en España llamamos bbc
es decir bodas batices y comuniones sino
que por ejemplo para que os hagáis una
idea esta empresa estuvo detrás de la
versión ucraniana de Bailando con las
estrellas irónicamente algunos de los
directores y productores rusos con los
que trabajó como marat basado
públicamente la invasión rusa de Ucrania
pero no fue ese el programa que le llevó
a lo más alto de su carrera sino que lo
hizo una serie de televisión titulada el
servidor del pueblo emitida entre los
años 2015 y 2019 en ella zelens que
interpreta el papel de un profesor que
tras ser grabado criticando la
corrupción del país en una de sus clases
se hace viral y termina convirtiéndose
en el presidente del país esta serie le
dio el impulso definitivo para entrar en
política fundando un partido con el
mismo nombre que la propia serie y
presentándose a las elecciones como una
auténtica Rockstar Sin embargo a pesar
de este gran trampolín hubo algún otro
factor adicional que contribuye a su
es todo un galán de telenovela y carisma
no le falta
[Música]
Pues bien también tenemos que tener en
cuenta el contexto social que vivía
Ucrania En aquel momento el país ya
estaba parcialmente invadido por Rusia
pero no solo eso los ucranianos estaban
terriblemente descontentos con la clase
política la revolución del euromaidam
prometió una nueva Ucrania cercana a
Europa y libre de corrupción Sin embargo
a pesar de que se hicieran alguna
reformas el problema de la corrupción
nunca llegó a terminarse digamos que
Ucrania seguía siendo en la práctica el
mismo país con los mismos problemas de
siempre solo habían cambiado algunas
caras muchos ucranianos se sentían como
si hubieran sustituido a políticos
corruptos prorusos por políticos
corruptos por occidentales así que en
2019 hasta un 60% de los ciudadanos
afirmaban sentir un gran descontento por
el presidente porroshenko Ucrania seguía
sin terminar su transición al
capitalismo de Libre Mercado y
continuaba a la corrupción como Norma
habitual Esto es algo que hemos cubierto
largo y tendido en otros vídeos de
visualpolitik
Pues bien es Entonces cuando entra en
escena zelensky En aquel momento en las
elecciones seguía teniendo bastante peso
el viejo debate de siempre estará buenas
con Rusia o a buenas con occidente y
Pese a que la invasión rusa de crimea
cambió radicalmente el punto de vista de
muchos ucranianos desde 2014 todavía
había muchos que por sus raíces
socioculturales y familiares no sentían
tanta animadversión por Moscú por eso
telesti que no era un político
claramente inclinado hacia ninguno de
los dos bandos fue visto como una
especie de tercera vía Y por supuesto
hablamos de alguien que viene del mundo
del espectáculo y que no dudó en meter
algo de Show en la política incluso
aunque esto supusiera tener que ser algo
populista además para él el problema
principal de Ucrania no era ni Rusia ni
occidente sino la corrupción y el
establis no soy un político soy un tipo
normal que viene a romper el sistema
pocos esperaban que ganara recuerdo de
hecho que aquí en visualpolitik la
primera vez que hablamos de este hombre
fue de hecho durante la campaña
electoral nos parecía simplemente Una
curiosidad más para Añadir al vídeo pero
nada serio sin embargo aquí llegó la
primera
un cómico tiene una aplastante victoria
en las elecciones presidenciales
ucranianas Petro polochenko concede la
derrota Mientras que bolonia el 70% de
los votos prometiendo no voy a fallar y
como no podía ser de otro modo su
inauguración fue todo lo que os podéis
esperar de un perfil tan peculiar
selfies con los fans en la entrada del
palacio presidencial
El caso es que como ya os hemos contado
su campaña estuvo marcada por un fuerte
discurso antiestablemente y cuando
hablamos de establishment hablamos sobre
todo de políticos corruptos oligarcas
multimillonarios y los vínculos entre
todos ellos delanski consideraba que la
prioridad ante todo era luchar contra la
corrupción para poder así transformar la
sociedad y la economía ucranianas y
convertirlas en algo homologable a los
países europeos te contaré sobre la
Ucrania de mis sueños es un Ucrania
donde solo tomó una hora iniciar un
negocio toma 15 minutos obtener un
pasaporte y toma un segundo votar en las
elecciones donde los médicos y maestros
reciben salarios reales y los
funcionarios corruptos tiempo real en la
cárcel extracto de un discurso electoral
delanski vamos que el programa de
ceranski era simple Pero efectivo una
burocracia simple la modernización de
Ucrania y principalmente acabar con la
corrupción y diréis pero fue todo esto
un Brindis al sol pues la realidad es
que zelensky intentó llevar a cabo
Muchas de sus promesas por ejemplo
introdujo reformas para acabar con la
inmunidad de los diputados aunque esta
es una medida bastante discutible pero
eso está para otro vídeo También produjo
un mecanismo de moción de censura para
que el parlamento pueda destituir al
presidente más allá en el terreno
económico zelensky firmó por ejemplo la
ley de liberalización del suelo agrícola
que como vimos en vídeos anteriores fue
un paso de gigante en la transición de
Ucrania a un capitalismo más parecido al
de sus vecinos del Oeste ahora bien
tampoco podemos pasar por alto sus
sombras
[Música]
por ejemplo zelensky llegó a incluir
hasta 30 amigos de su antigua productora
fartal 95 en el gobierno lo que por
supuesto despertó muchas dudas pero no
sólo eso también se le ha criticado por
aparecer en los famosos Pandora papers
tanto él como sus antiguos compañeros de
farta al 95 tenían empresas axore y
propiedades en Londres y por supuesto
tener empresas en países de baja
tributación no es un delito en sí mismo
y sí tenéis razón es más en países con
tan poca seguridad jurídica como Ucrania
resulta casi obligatorio es algo así
como una vía para escapar de los
oligarcas locales y cubrirte las
espaldas de forma completamente legal lo
que en cambio sí puede ser más
cuestionable es su conexión con Igor
colomoysky Un conocido oligarco
ucraniano colomosky fue uno de los
principales apoyos en la campaña de
zelensky Sin embargo este hombre ha sido
investigado y juzgado por casos de
corrupción durante años estuvo en el
exilio para evitar ir a la cárcel pero
tras la victoria de zelensky volvió a
Ucrania y empezó a ganar varios casos
judiciales que tenía en contra
evidentemente ahí más dudas
lo que sí podemos decir es que antes de
la guerra felen que había defraudado las
altísimas expectativas de los ucranianos
pasado de ser uno de los políticos más
populares del país a caer en picado en
las encuestas atentos el fin de la
alternativa zelanski las encuestas de
octubre de 2021 han sido un shock para
el equipo presidencial los ratios de
aprobación de han bajado del 33,3% de
septiembre al 24,7% en Octubre y luego
llegó la amenaza de Invasión rusa una
amenaza que le ha supuesto críticas
porque el bueno de bolodimir estaba
convencido de que no se produciría sé
que mucha gente pensaba que quizás
exageraba Pero sabía que teníamos
información para sostener que Putin iba
a entrar a cruzar la frontera no había
duda Pero ángeles que mucha gente no
querían oírlo entiendo por qué no
querían oírlo Pero al final ocurrió Joe
biden presidente de los Estados Unidos
sin embargo Todo cambió el 24 de febrero
Ese fue el día que lo cambió todo ahora
mismo vamos a ver lo que pasó
El Cómico se pone serio
el 24 de febrero se consolida lo que
tanto se temía Rusia invadió un país
soberano y desató el terror sobre
Ucrania prácticamente nadie pensaba que
Ucrania podría resistir los números y la
diferencia de fuerzas parecía Clara
Incluso en los líderes occidentales le
ofrecieron a zelensky la posibilidad de
escapar del país pensando por un momento
si Rusia hubiera llegado a tomar gif
cosa que se pensaba que era bastante
probable en ese momento selens que
habría sido el primero en ser detenido y
quizás incluso ejecutado en estas
circunstancias lo que cualquiera hubiera
esperado es que pusiera tierra de por
medio no es la primera vez que pasa de
hecho el propio Víctor yanucovich huyó
de Ucrania durante la revueltas del
euromaidan y es en este momento cuando
voló dimir zelemski pronunció esa frase
que pasará a la historia necesito
munición no un paseo
Claro que lo más difícil no es No
dejarse capturar sino resistir una
brutal invasión por parte de un ejército
muchísimo mayor
en este sentido zelensky se quedó para
ganar no sólo tuvo la debería de
quedarse sino que aprovechó
magníficamente el momento para ganarse
el apoyo de todo el mundo las cosas como
son las que ha conseguido el apoyo sin
paliativos de la otan de repente un país
que muchos no sabrían Ubicar en el mapa
con exactitud se ha colocado en el
centro del tablero político y alguno
dirá venga ya todo el mundo sabía que
occidente acudiría al rescate de Ucrania
pues lo cierto Es que no no era algo que
estuviera nada Claro sin embargo gracias
a la tenacidad de zelensky del gobierno
y el ejército ucraniano de repente las
puertas de la solidaridad Se abrieron de
par en par fijaos en esta gráfica aquí
podéis ver todo el dinero que se ha
enviado Ucrania tanto en concepto de
ayuda humanitaria como de armas Estados
Unidos encabeza con mucha diferencia al
ranking pero la Unión Europea también ha
puesto bastante dinero sobre la mesa
para apoyar a Ucrania dinero y
sacrificios solo tenemos que echar un
vistazo a la crisis energética que
atravesamos
[Música]
por supuesto que a todo occidente le
interesa que Ucrania gane esta guerra
vamos a decirlo claro enviar armas
Ucrania es la inversión más barata que
puede hacer Europa y en términos de
seguridad cada minuto que pasa Rusia
está perdiendo dinero armas y soldados y
cada vez parece más difícil que puedan
No ya conquistar más territorio
ucraniano sino incluso resistir ahora
bien Esto es lo que sabemos ahora en
febrero de 2022 pocos se hubieran
atrevido imaginar que Rusia fuera
semejante tigre de papel y poco se
imaginaban que el ejército ucraniano muy
inferior en todos los números podría
resistir de la forma en la que lo ha
hecho este hombre podrá tener muchos
defectos pero su capacidad de persuasión
será legendaria en los primeros meses de
la guerra dio discursos en prácticamente
todos los parlamentos de los países de
la otan y en cada uno de ellos supo
adaptarse y tocar Las fibra sensible de
todos y cada uno de los países
[Música]
por ejemplo en Estados Unidos
cuando se dirigió al parlamento alemán
aseguró que debían ayudarlo a tirar
abajo Este muro refiriéndose a un muro
impuesto por los rusos contra la
libertad esto era una Clara referencia
al muro de Berlín y al mítico discurso
de Ronald Reagan en la puerta de
brandenburgo por supuesto para pelar al
pueblo inglés usó la memoria de
Churchill asegurando que seguirían
peleando por su tierra sin importar el
precio en los bosques bahías y en las
calles
y diréis pues menudo comercial Pues sí
tenéis razón a estas alturas creo que
sería capaz de venderme un peine incluso
a mí pero eso es justo lo que necesitaba
Ucrania y sigue necesitando a día de hoy
Gracias a esta estrategia de
comunicación el ejército de Ucrania se
ha podido aprovisionar de toda clase de
armas pero no solo eso se leensky
también ha sabido inspirar a todo el
pueblo ucraniano para que resista de
nuevo ahora aparece algo evidente Pero
qué habríamos pensado en febrero de 2022
[Música]
feliz que ha estado prácticamente todas
las noches desde que empezó la invasión
motivando la lucha a través de
publicaciones en redes sociales todos
vimos su retransmisiones desde las
calles de Kid cuando el ejército ruso
estaba en las puertas de la ciudad
mensajes como este han servido para que
la sociedad ucraniana tuviera esperanza
y
resistieran esos
pero el contagioso optimismo de zelensky
no se queda ahí sino que ya está incluso
buscando inversores para la posguerra
los inversores para buscar cooperación a
largo plazo con Ucrania y hay que
reconocer que por el momento no leído
del todo mal ya ha conseguido que
blackrock que la mayor a gestora de
fondos de inversión del mundo se
comprometa a darle asesoramiento y a
buscar inversores pero no solo eso el
mismo celanski abrió la bolsa de Nueva
York en septiembre para lanzar una
campaña de inversión asegurando que ya
han empezado a reconstruir lo que Rusia
ha destruido todavía no sabemos Cuántos
inversores estarán dispuestos a apostar
por Ucrania pero sí podemos decir una
cosa en lo que al campo militar respecta
este país ha conseguido un milagro y
tenemos que reconocer que tiene muy
buena parte de la responsabilidad
[Música]
el ejército ucraniano ya ha recuperado
miles de kilómetros cuadrados del
territorio invadido por Rusia ha
conseguido que se retiren de kit de
parte de loblas de gersón e incluso ha
realizado ataques en crimea claro que si
bien celebramos los avances de zelensky
tal y como ya hemos dicho el presidente
también ha tenido ciertas sombras en sus
primeros años significa esto que no
merezca nuestro aplauso para nada sus
logros este año le garantizan desde
luego una página en los libros de
historia ahora bien cuidado con crear un
Mesías pero ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros decepcionar A helensky y se
convertirá en un falso Mesías estamos
hablando de una especie de nuevo
Churchill Rusia escalará esta guerra con
armas más potentes podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribías
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]